eu ouvi alguém agora vamos fechar não dá
não dá nunca a chapa do macaco
o lado diz pessoal de quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais um
peão e o estrago de quifa finais e quem
diz que é um novo ninguém faz nada sem
fred segue o gol eu sei que alguns de
vocês já estão um pouco fartos que eu
traga funny games finais é fredes mais
chão parece estar mesmo muito bom jogo
até foi aprovado pelos quatro cantos de
tudo e pronto intitulado bomba cai
primeira noite meia noite está em 3d
não quero hábito mensagem exatamente
animatronics chamas candy e são dois é o
march filme é isso que o o hospital foi
à janela é alguém vai passar e que ok
temos portas mas não temos luz onde
foram parar as luzes ok temos muitas
salas apagadas
nada temos neste sítio como é que as
costas garisto alô
alguns estão aqui para os herdeiros luz
de stop já escrevi acender luzes e olha
aí está tudo apagado tem interesse algum
botão falou isso não funciona
estamos sem luz na pizzaria o que é
estúpido porque nós temos no nosso foco
em ganhar uma e depois lá fora nada duas
barulho é este que barulho rs tem alguém
na câmara cinco supostamente a câmera
assim que elas enfrentem é que eu vou
fechar isto não sei o que está passando
não saiba tudo apagado não se achar isto
alguém me silvia fundos também nós não
fizemos por nenhuma porque a música está
cada vez mais alta porque nossa bateria
supostamente uma pilha deve estar aí com
80% assim por isso eu acho que tudo bem
nas duas da manhã com 80% e eu acho que
tudo bem mas eu quero ver a cor das
câmaras têm de vir aqui algum botão a
uma cena assim deve ser este computador
aqui é alguma coisa que eu tenho que
fazer isso não é normal tem dúvida que
algum botão para eu acenderia shopping
los
é o bota não o que é o são olhos aquilo
são olhos estão ali mas foi em óleo nos
deixa
nas outras salas e visitei o tac o outro
para a câmera 2 no quilômetro 12 horas
caiu será que é só isto e não sair mais
alguém na câmara dois e nervoso
ok temos que controlar a câmera 2 já
está perto da câmera 5 e vai avançar a
seguir por aqui eu tenho que fechar a
janela
após também tem só quatro da manhã não
fizemos nada ainda nada as luzes nem
sendo bem e já são quatro da manhã e
vamos parar um pouco aqui dentro ver seu
avanço ou não
o galo avançou avançou o décimo deu o zé
manel dos olhos da câmera 2 a cantar
ópera foi panoff isabel foi para novo eu
acho que só o som dois supostamente é o
que machuca de fêmea
eu acho que é isso mas com armas em
manter o nível não saímos de um só vez
quatro onde 4 gb funpar dois para ter um
lote 12
a minha matemática é excelente golo
certo tá aproximando se aproximou o neto
está a chegar à tua súmulas ou não que
eu não consegui ver eu não sei qual
deles é o azul e rosa
aqui não sei eu nem tenho luz aqui meu
eu não consegui ver só a minha porta não
também nós nada
não consigo ouvir nada
eu estou sentindo aqui dentro do sentir
aquele cheiro e gato dentro do meu foco
é escritor e homem vai me ajudar eu vou
fechar as portas vão fechar as portas
que não tem bateria que esperam
incluídas mas eles não conseguem ver mas
eu tô que tô aqui eu tô aqui né tá aqui
eu vou fechar a porta para que abracem
quiser eu vou manter a janela fechada e
está mesmo à minha frente eu sei lá eu
sei lá um dueto taxa caiu foi patrícia
rocha possibilite né
eu acho que sim não apareceu ninguém até
agora mas eu acho que por eu estar a
jogar banho supostamente um dos lados
imitá-la não eu já sei o voto em você e
utah na câmara trecho não está na câmara
três e outro
não digo enquanto a outra está aqui
dentro vai ser tudo quanto está aqui
dentro muito estava aqui e não sei o que
canta atrás mínimas têm olhos eu
consegue ver os assim o senhor
isso aqui está tudo tranquilo só sei que
amanhã ou seis nós queremos passar a
primeira noite eu não sei eu não sei o
que aconteceu aqui eu não sei como é que
edgar esta porcaria as câmeras estavam
todas apagadas mas temos que passar a
primeira noite já é bom o calouro em
fita de minigames mãe uma câmera ou mais
foco no negócio tá aqui o papa há mais
alguma coisa que não sei como vai ficar
agora supostamente nós temos uma quebra
mas não está com câmeras né eu vou me
assustar aqui e vai por ser qualquer
coisa isso não é normal eu não consigo
enxergar câmeras canon 7d sim tem que
arranjar alguma coisa ela percebeu a lei
eu estava olhando para a câmera treino
de dois toques suaves tem 82 precisamos
jogar já neste episódio a segunda noite
dos painéis é de quem apesar não ter
acontecido quase nada e tudo gostar
muito deste jogo porque só pelo fato de
escama estarem apagados o time alguém na
câmara o novo só há uma câmera 12 a uma
câmera nova nesta noite o orçamento vai
por cima de palhaços né
mas como estava a dizer o tux tarde
junto ao mesmo pelo fato das câmeras
estarem apagados que está assim é que o
ministério de vocês não saberem pro
nécton olhar e o que está do outro lado
apesar de já temos aqui os posters de
metrô next né
eu acho que são este não sai o suspeito
é e josé palhares agora supostamente
também vai por ser esta noite não sair
mas espero que não porque eu vou
controlar muito bem as portas que
barulho que música música é esta música
você pagasse né o site é palhaça
consulta sempre essa musiquinha é sempre
usar palavras esta [ __ ]
calma calma dark tem calma contigo da
arkham city da câmara 8 mil segundo a
câmara eu estar aqui agora 70 muito
perto de mim aliás não é pertinho vai
até a câmara porque tem jogos mais perto
né
ok só quando eu fui pra lançar isso é
que eu vou fechar a porta
ou então passar assim comprar quatro não
sai mas são estas as portas mais perto
de mim por isso eu vou te dar prioridade
a estas câmeras não é o ídolo meu café e
agora e houve alguém andar e eu ouvi
alguém andar e vamos fechar não dá não
dá no bairro à porta o macaco
quem aprecia um macaco que o show o jogo
fechou o todo suado
eu não percebi o que aconteceu aqui mas
o próximo macaco por ser um funk macaco
não era nada de gatos nem nada que se
pareça e um jogo sujo eu não sei o que
aconteceu mas eu acho que nós vamos
chegar porque com estes gameplay do
fight night candy se vocês quiserem mais
vestiu de mamãe nos comentários deixa o
nosso apoio como fazem sempre ajudou a
durar o vosso podia ser só voz estão
apoiar mesmo morto por isso dou um beijo
no rafa todos vocês não mas é espero
fazer isso num estado já sabem como é
que eles acharam um estilo que querem
ver mais um não e é isso fique bem e até
a próxima